bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france le premier ministre
britannique boris johnson dit donc
espérer un retour à la quasi normal en
angleterre d'ici fin juin
est ce réaliste selon vous le taux de 2
des créations de thé de la maladie est
assez frappant l'est tous les indices
que ce soit de d'hospitalisation de
nouvelles infections sont fortement en
baisse et ce partout sur le sur le
territoire donc il ya eu un vrai
changement de paradigme et et les il ya
eu des tests grande échelle de
l'indication en et casse par exemple
portant sur l'efficacité de des vaccins
et c'est le résultat de ces tests sont
également très positif pour instruire et
que c'était même pour les personnes les
plus âgées amap ou 2 94% donc et le
nombre de personnes qui ont été
vaccinées au royaume uni a je pense que
ça frôle les 40% et ils sont toujours en
plein déploiement d'une campagne de
grande ampleur et qui mobilise pour
qu'aussi la société civile et beaucoup
de volontaires qui aident dans les
centres de vaccination donc ça bouge
énormément et qui dans le bon sens donc
on ya quand même quelques motifs
d'espoir alors pour l'instant cette
réouverture des écoles ne concernent que
l'angleterre mais c'est parce que le
construit le système politique du
royaume uni se base sur une union
composé des quatre nations et y dans
certains domaines à il y à une
décentralisation des pouvoirs beaucoup
plus forte que ce qu'on peut imaginer en
france et c'est le cas pour le système
de santé aussi pour les écoles dans sa
salle axes le lait ce qui se commande
aujourd'hui concerne l'angleterre serait
né dans les trois autres nations il ya
une gestion
no 15 et je puis dire de leur situation
est-ce que vous pensez que cette sortie
du confinement se peut cette stratégie
dictée par boris johnson va être
réalisable en ouverture la réunion déjà
de six personnes
à l'extérieur la réouverture en
prochainement ça arrive très bientôt des
bars des restaurants est ce que il va
pouvoir se tenir à ce plan à la boris
johnson et et comme tout responsable
intelligent il aura ir regardera les
fêtes
au fur et à mesure donc on ne peut pas
dire aujourd'hui les incertitudes de
100% que tout soit terminé et abouti
dans les temps mais il son propos est
justement de d'organiser et d'annoncés
pour encourager les gens une le
processus par étapes qui est prudent
mais optimiste en même temps donc je
pense qu'il ya de bonnes raisons de
penser que ça va que ça va marcher mais
il lui raconte comment français comme
comme dit le président macron on
regardera ce qui se passait sur le sur
le terrain et on ajustera si nécessaire
me donner le but est clairement annoncée
est d'éviter a encore un autre
confinement celui dont on consomme étant
le quatrième on fait tout pour que ce
soit le dernier
faut dire et vous le disais qu'il ya une
baisse des contaminations une baisse des
hospitalisations en est à 22 millions de
personnes qui ont été vaccinées avec
leurs premières doses est ce que c'est
un succès pour vous cette campagne de
vaccination et crée ton uniopss mais
aucun doute là dessus
et ce qui est d'abord par le nombre de
personnes également je le disais un
instant temps de la mobilisation et de
la société civile dont on nous parle pas
beaucoup dans les médias mais il y à des
volontaires des avocats
avec une journée sur le travail qui se
rendent dans les centres de vaccination
simplement pour rassurer pour guider les
personnes qui avaient pour qu'il trouve
le bon endroit où la vaccination a lieu
et les gens concernés selon les le
développement du programme reçoit ils ne
sont pas obligés de téléphoner qui m'ont
demandé un rendez-vous non ils sont
contactés
voilà vous êtes sur la liste dans les
jours qui viennent ensuite quelques
créneaux qui est nouveau proposant
indiquez-nous lequel vous conviendra le
mieux
et la personne s'est rangé des
témoignages et a fait de bout de
quelques minutes je n'ai pas
d'engorgement tata n'a pas d'éthique
tant qu'opposition c'est évidement cette
c'est très positif mais pour par rapport
à l'être écologique du pays c'est
extrêmement important parce que ça donne
vraiment un peu d'espoir aux gens en
général cette fois une mauvaise nouvelle
qui risque d'aviver pour pour les
britanniques c'est ces annonces 17 % de
déficit du pib en 2020
résultat une hausse des impôts est prévu
alors ce sera en 2023 c'est encore dans
un petit moment mais l'impôt sur les
sociétés va passer de 19 à 20 à 25%
comment est ce que cela va être
accueilli par les britanniques
il y a déjà eu des commentaires déçus
parce que ça a été annoncé la semaine
dernière
c'est vrai que ça donnait lieu à des
propos contrastaient même des journaux
comme de télé terre de gauche qui
soutiennent pas des conservateurs
habituellement ont émis quelques doutes
sur le sujet
néanmoins il y a je pense que c'est une
bonne politique qui se veut réaliste
aussi niari qu il y a pour d'être année
d'ici là essayer 2023 à une politique
forte stimulation de l'économie par des
crédits d'impôts ou des entreprises très
important de 130 % sur les
investissements ce qui est de nature à
aa orages et de niveaux d'investissement
naturel si je puis dire de la vie
économique en sortant du confinement
donc le pari du gon et qu' il y aura
près de mille détails en 2021 un rebond
fort de l'économie et permettra d'amener
ces hausses d'impôts à partir de demain
merci beaucoup pas le thème scène pour
toutes ces précisions je rappelle que
vous êtes vice-président du parti
conservateur britannique en france merci
à vous